Good morning Hank, it's Friday. I have a 101.2°
fever; we'll see if that affects my video
making.
So Nerdfighteria, I was so impressed with
your Gussie Manlove hunting skills that today
I am sending you on a new quest to solve a
427-year-old mystery, starring Ivan the Terrible.
He's looking at me, isn't he? Uwuughhh! You're
so scary looking. Why are you looking at me?
Okay Hank, first off when it comes to Kings
and Tsars, 'Great' does not mean better than
good, and 'Terrible' does not mean worse than
bad, although that's a common mistake. 'Great'
and 'Terrible' in their classical meanings
are actually quite similar, they both have
connotations of power and might and authority.
Okay Hank, picture this - I know I need to
button the button - you're three years old
and your dad dies of a leg boil. You wanna
know why it's better to be middle class in
the 21st century, than it is to be incredibly
rich in the 15th century? Very rarely do people
currently die of leg boils. Right so you're
three years old and your dad dies, which means
that technically you're now the King of Russia,
which is a terrible gig because like, you're
mostly potty trained, but you're not totally
ready to run a country.
So that means you need a regent. Fortunately,
your mom is available to be your regent. Unfortunately,
when you're eight, the nobility kills her.
So you're eight, you've got all these nobility,
these boyers, running around the palace fighting
with each other over who should rule the show,
and you hate them. Because they killed your
mom, and they also make you nervous because
they might kill you.
But when you turn 16 and you take over the
throne you decide "Y'know I'm not going to
focus all my energy on negativity, on getting
rid of these boyers. I'm gonna make the world
better"
You modernize the legal code, you open up
trade with Europe, you annex a bunch of land
and make Russia look more like... Russia,
and you marry this beautiful girl named Anastasia.
Hank, here is a lesson from history: Never
be Russian and named Anastasia.
Yeah so then in 1560, your wife dies and you
think the boyers did it, and you're like "They
killed my mom, they made me very anxious when
I was a child, and now, I think they killed
my wife". So then you start to be more traditionally
terrible. You start a really ill-advised war,
you have this quasi-police force that goes
around massacring boyers and also anyone else
they come across, and then you beat your pregnant
daughter-in-law until she has a miscarriage,
and then your son Ivan-should've-been-the-fifth
comes up to you and he's like "Dad, I wish
you hadn't done that" and you kill him. In
your defense, you didn't mean to kill him,
you meant to, y'know, hit him. But he died.
But Hank, in your role as Ivan the Terrible,
that is not even the worst thing you ever
did. The worst was this - 427 years ago you
died! In the middle of a chess game! Without
telling anyone where your incredibly fancy
library is!
Sorry, I get very upset when people screw
around with libraries.
Your grandfather, Ivan the Third, married
a Byzantine lady. By Byzantine, I don't mean
like, complicated, I mean like of Byzantium.
As her dowry, she brought with her a beautiful
library full of illuminated manuscripts encrusted
in jewels so valuable that the king of Russia
was like "Man, we have got to hide this".
So they built an underground library somewhere
underneath Moscow - there are like thousands
of miles of tunnels underneath Moscow because
it's the perfect sand for tunneling, or something.
And that would have worked fine except Ivan
the Terrible was so obsessed with killing
boyers and expanding Russia and becoming the
first real Tsar that he completely forgot
about the library and died without telling
anyone where it was.
In short Hank, if the legends are true, there
are right now underneath Moscow billions of
dollars worth of books. And so for the last
427 years, people have been searching for
it. Nerdfighters, that is my task for you!
I have created a thread in Your Pants - link
in the doobly doo - where together, we can
search out information so that we might uncover
everything that there is to be known about
that great and terrible library.
Hank, I'll see you on Monday.